hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're gonna
be going over the bloomenfeld at gamba
derives from the benoni defense which is
d4 Knight f6 c4 then after pushing to c5
attack in the center of the board here a
d5 and then e six this is the modern
Benoni lots of different variations that
black has you have the Banco gambit here
with b5 you have the modern Bodoni with
e6 and you have the Czech benoni which
we just did a video on with E 5 but
after the modern benoni on e6 the most
common response from white is to play
Knight to f3 now they don't have to play
that but for the blumenfield gambit we
are gonna be looking at Knight to f3 and
then pawn to b5 and this is the setup
that we're gonna be looking at few
variations both from the accepted line
as well as if they decline and when I
say accepted specifically mean if they
go up material now they could just take
here on b5 but they're not gonna go up
in material yes we are giving up a pawn
that is the gambit piece but just taking
right away that's not gaining material
because the pawn can just recapture yes
the Queen is attacking the pawn but our
Knight is defending this square here on
d5 if maybe they tried something Bishop
down here to g5 pinning down the knight
so it can't defend it anymore
Bishop to b7 is the Savior no longer
able to attack this pond yes has double
pawns in the center not the best setup
for black but also White has double
pawns on the B file and this pawn here
on a b5 is pretty awkwardly play so you
know maybe now III Bishop to e7 getting
ready to castle on the King side so you
really don't see that line very often if
they are going to accept it generally
that means that they're gonna take here
on e6 Black's gonna recapture with his F
pawn wants to maintain both of the
center pawns that's why you're generally
not gonna see the pawn recapture here
also opens up the door for the Queen's
to trade off the board a lot of players
are not looking to do that early on in
the game so F pawn takes here on e6 and
then the pawn takes here on b5 so white
yes is up material that's part
of the point of the gambit and black is
looking to control the center of the
board so white had the pawn here on a d5
and a c4 and black is giving up material
so that black can control the center of
the board and really be the one that's
aggressive in this setup now from here
black has a few options a lot of people
will immediately play d5 attacking the
center of the board trying to control it
with the pawns here personally that's
not what I feel like is the easiest to
play because you just have a really
awkward place to pawn here on e6 and
we'll get into exactly what that looks
like and why I think it's somewhat
awkward but I like to keep the pawn back
here on d7 instead play Bishop to b7
because this controls these light
squares in the center of the board white
at some point wants to be playing pawn
to e4 opening up trying to control the
center open up for his lighter Bishop
castle on the Kings side and this allows
black to kind of sit back still control
the center with his minor pieces you
have the knight here you have the bishop
here on b7 but wait and not really
commit to anything yet with his D pawn
so from here you could see Knight to c3
and then black could play Bishop to e7
and then you start to look at how
White's going to continue they're not
going to be playing pawn to e4 that
doesn't make sense because Knight could
just take here on e4 this Knight is
protected by the bishop so that's not
really going to happen
they could play e3 castle on the King
side this has a very similar vibe to the
King's gambit where you castle you have
very safe King but you have a very
active rook here this pot over here
their double pawns on the B file you're
gonna get that material back at some
point but black has a very aggressive
board state right here now if they don't
go to e3
maybe instead they decide to after
Bishop to e7 they play Queens
- see - this is a pretty common square
for the Queen to come to once this
c-file pawn moves because starts to
attack the King side I would still
castle on the King side your nights here
on f6 is doing a very solid job
protecting at this square over here on
h7 and you just have a very aggressive
rook here on FA so I think this is the
way to go and if you ever need to you
can swing your Bishop over here get that
involved into the action as well be
prepared that you're gonna be playing
some a6 at some point so you know from
here if they were to play E for I'm
gonna be looking to play a6 break up
this pawn structure right here you can
get your rook involved into the game so
really start to attack the the Queen
side of the board so that's what happens
if they play Knight to c3 after we play
that Bishop to b7 now if you don't play
Bishop to d7 cuz a lot of people if you
look at a different commentary or if you
just look at different options that you
have upon to d5 the reason I personally
don't like it as much is because from
here Knight to c3 fairly common as we've
talked about now if you were to try
Bishop to b7 which you don't have to but
Knight to g5 is pretty awkward this has
you know this Knight attacking this
backward pawn here on e6 now you can
definitely get out of this
you could play queen up here to d6 this
is defending this I just don't
necessarily like it as much and this
Knight is way too much in my business
for for what I like to do so instead
what if Bishop doesn't come to b7 may be
Bishop to e7
but then Knight to e4 it's just kind of
awkward I really like protecting it with
my bishop over here now why would they
do that because you may just look at and
say can't can't black just take here
because you know pawn takes and you know
you got the Knights here and the night's
gonna recapture that looks good for for
black but actually
the black pond can't take here on e4
because then you're just gonna see the
Queen come down here take on d8 and then
after the bishop takes then the key move
here is Knight to g5 so this Knight is
attacking both the pawn here on e4 and
the backward pawn here on e6 that we
already talked about pretty awkward and
this Knight here on a c3 is also
attacking this pawn here on e4 White's
also looking to get his bishop here to
see for adding another attacker
right here black doesn't have a lot of
safety for his King both of his pawns
are pushed forward his bishops are back
here on a d8 and c8 so that's why black
can't take here so because he's not
taking here where does he really
continue from here I mean he he could
try some other options and just maybe
castle on the King side but then they
could push forward to e5 and this is
really a tough spot this keeps the pawn
back here on e6 as a backward pawn Black
has a more cramped position than I like
so that's why while yes you are
controlling the center of the board with
your pawns I prefer when we come back
here as far as how black continues from
this setup right here after the accepted
lines to just play Bishop to b7 all
right so let's look at some lines if
they do not accept and one of those
would be playing efore and it looks a
little awkward because right away you
say yeah the knight can just take here
on e4 yes that is true but remember it
is a gambit so they can always get a
pawn back in material meaning they could
take here and then after we recapture
with our pond they could take with their
own pond both sides are equal in
material now black has a much better
setup white has double pawns here and
then you can play this Queen to a5 now
before in all the setups they could just
play Knight to c3 or they already had
knight on c3 that's a little awkward now
because we have the knight on e4 that
can take obviously they can't just
recapture we are forking their rook here
on a1 with
the check here so this is going to be a
completely fine setup if they were to
capture material back they don't have to
take with their pawns here another
option that they do have is a bishop
here to d3 attacking the knight it's
pretty awkward if you try to push
forward here with f5 and hold on to that
material usually just gonna bring your
knight back to f6 you could bring it
back here to d6 as well but I find it
more advantageous to bring it back here
to f6 to make sure you have a defender
for this h7 pawn from here if they take
material that's completely okay you can
just recapture if now they take you have
some options you could get your queen
involved into the game that's fine you
could just play Bishop here to e7 castle
on the king's head but that's the reason
that they might play E for early on
because they still have a lot of good
options even though initially it kind of
looks awkward that they're just giving
up one of their center pawns to your
Knights it's not a free pawn by any
means another option that they do have
is this awkward d6
of just saying yes you're giving up upon
a material keep in mind from the very
beginning of the game you push forward
with c5 and they say I'm not gonna take
that I'm gonna play d5 here so already
in their mind they like to not take and
push forward here and after e6 and then
they play Knight to f3 pawn up here to
b5 they could say yeah I'm just gonna
play d6 it's being protected by the
Queen here on d1 so that's completely
fine now black has the option of playing
Queen to a5 check but I feel like if
they're gonna play this game you almost
have to play b4 completely fine option
and you just have to let them know hey
if you're not gonna take my pawns I'm
gonna play the same game they have to
know that you are running the game just
look them in the eye and tell them that
you are the captain now you're not gonna
be playing their shenanigans you run the
chess board now from here as far as how
they could continue maybe Bishop to
F for protecting the pond right here now
Queen to b6 this is adding another
attacker on this d6 square you could at
some point play Knight to h5 attacking
the bishop it can't come back here to g3
because the knight is covering that
square but first I like to get the Queen
over here to b6 you have a very active
Queen side of the board so while this
both defends both your pawns it also
does attack the square here on d6 so
that's an option if they play d6 not
super common but every now and then you
will see some really weird moves from
your opponent after you play this gambit
here on to b5 and then the last option
is Knight to c3 don't think you'll see
it too often but if you do probably
pretty obvious since we just looked at
that laceration you're just going to
push forward here to b4 you're giving up
that material here on b4 for central
attack but if they don't want to take it
b4 is very difficult for them to worry
about on the Queen side of the board and
you still have a very very sound King
side as well now how do they really
continue yeah if they take here you take
you have a good center of the board you
can push forward here you could play
Bishop to b7 you can easily play Bishop
to e7 castle on the King side have a
very active King side as well with your
rook here on f1 so all in all very very
good gambit so definitely benoni defense
if you don't play it all too much I
highly recommend it when you get into
these lines with the d4 and c4 you just
have so many different variations the
modern Brno benoni
one of the more popular lines and when
you start seeing that Knight to f3 I
definitely recommend trying this out
because it is a fun one indeed but
hopefully guys and enjoyed this video
I've had a lot of requests for different
variations specifically in the benoni
that's why I've made these videos if
there are other variations other opening
lines that we'd like me to make you can
always leave a comment or the best way
is to reach out to me you can email me
at the chess website at gmail.com or if
you go to the website the chess website
calm there
is a chat functionality on the website
you can chat directly with me yes it is
gonna be me that is responding to so
feel free to do that I will respond as
fast as I can but you can always let me
know if there are videos you would like
me to make thank you guys so much for
watching the video and I will see you
guys next time
you